الارجنتين المرشح للفوز بكاس العالم جنبا
الى جنب مع البرازيل الثالث في تصنيف
الفيفا العالمي الارجنتين القيمه
التسويقيه للاعبيها تقترب من 750 مليون
يورو والمونديال الاخير لميسي كل هذا نضعه
جانبا الصقور الخضر ينقضون عليهم في
مباراههم الاولى بمونديال قطر وينهون
المباراه بهدفين لهدف ويكتبون فوزا
للتاريخ عن جداره واستحقاق
فوز ينهي سلسله الانتصارات المتتاليه
للارجنتين عندها 36 فوزا ويحبطوا ميسي
ورفاقه ويصعب عليهم مهمات العبور للدوري
المقبل في البطوله
صالح الشهري سالم الدوسري هدفان في خمس
دقائق يقلبان الكفه والموازين لصالح
الاخضر السعودي وخلفهم خط دفاع في قمه
انضباطه التكتيكي وحارس مرمى بطل يدعم
محمد العويس
ويؤمن بالفوز ويقدم مباراه العمر انها
مباراه لا تحصل كل يوم ولكل شهر ولا كل
سنه ولا ربما كل عقد بالامس شاهدنا
التاريخ
ليست مجرد ثلاث نقاط تاريخيه على احد اقوى
منتخبات العالم لكنه فوز يكتب ويسجل
العديد من الارقام لصالح المنتخب السعودي
وكاس العالم بشكل عام لاول مره في تاريخ
مشاركته لكاس العالم ليفتتح المنتخب
السعودي منافسته الموندياليه بالفوز وتلك
المره على راقصه تانجو في نفس الوقت تفتتح
الارجنتين مشوارها في كاس العالم بالخساره
لاول مره منذ سقوطها في مباراه الكاميرون
بمونديال 1990
فوز السعوديه على الارجنتين يكتب رابع
انتصار للصقور الخضر في منافسته بكاس
العالم وهو رقم عربي وقيسي متفوقا على
الجزائر الذي يملك ثلاث انتصارات هو اول
فوز عربي على منتخب من امريكا الجنوبيه في
كاس العالم منذ 40 عاما حين فازت الجزائر
على تشيلي في مونديال عام 1982
لاول مره منذ عام 1930 تخسر الارجنتين
المباراه في كاس العالم بعد تقدمها خلال
الشوط الاول واخيرا فوز الصقور يعني انهاء
سلسله الله هزيمه لمنتخب الارجنتين والتي
استمرت لست وثلاثين مباراه متتاليه
منصور يا بشعار يا سعودي يبقى المنتخب
فرحه كبيره تعبر عنها الجماهير السعوديه
بعد فوز منتخبها على منتخب الارجنتين
بنتيجه 2-1 كما نشاهد هنا في مدينه الخبر
الجماهير كلها خرجت الى شوارع للاحتفال
بهذا الفوز التاريخي منذ انطلاق صادره
النهايه حتى ساعات المساء والجماهير كلها
موجوده في الشوارع احتفالا في هذا الفوز
التاريخ التاريخ
العب يلا
[موسيقى]
خليجيه
جدا جميله من المنتخب واعضاء منتخب وافراد
ومنتخب فردا فردا نهال المنتخب والدوله
والملك ولي الملك كلهم الحمد لله بفوز
الجميل هذا اليوم المتفائل مباراه المكسيك
بولندا
كمان والسعوديه جده وقدود
كيف شفت المباراه اليوم مباراه الحمد لله
يعني ما كانت متوقعه بس هذا اللي في
السعوديين هذا اللي هذا اللي يجيه هذا
اللي يجيء يقول ميسي اقول ميسي والله
اسف والله احب ميسي بس اليوم وانا سعودي
اسفه والله
[موسيقى]
اكيد قبل المباراه كنت خايف وكنت متوقعها
نتيجه كبيره متى حسيت انه المنتخب السعودي
[موسيقى]
بس من بعد الحمد لله بعد ما الغوه الشوط
الثاني ادينا ممتاز وما خيب ظن الناس
مرتدات وعرف امكانيات لاعبين ايش رايك
والله
لعبها صح المدرب طموحنا عنان السماء مو بس
مباراه هذه ان شاء الله طموحنا فوق ونوصل
فوقه ان شاء الله كنت خايف من منتخب روتين
في المنتخب وبيضوها يعني كيف شفت مستوى
المنتخب اليوم ممتاز جدا فاجئني المستوى
المستوى جديد ومستوى عاليه
خساره للارجنتين في بطولات كاس العالم
امام منتخب عربي في التاريخ حدثنا من
الناحيه الفنيه
المنتخب السعودي ادخل الكثير من التفاؤل
الجماهير العربيه حتى المنتخبات العربيه
ايضا موجوده في كاس العالم استفادت من فوز
المنتخب السعودي المنتخب التونسي شفنا
يعني قدم اداء يعني قوي جدا وان شاء الله
تستمر مع المنتخب المغربي اليوم طبعا
المنتخب الارجنتيني كان مرشح الاول الفوز
وهمم الوصول المباراه النهائيه هذا طبعا
بقياده ميسي اخذت نجوم كبار في المنتخب
الارجنتيني المنتخب الارجنتيني 36 مباراه
بله خساره كانت تنقصه المباراه واحده
لمعادله الرقم القياسي لمنتخب ايطاليا 37
مباراه فالمنتخب السعودي اليوم نحسبه حرم
الارجنتينيين من هذا الانجاز
للامانه المنتخب السعودي
في اعلى مستوى حتى انا يعني بصراحه
التصريح المدرب
منتخب السعودي قال تصريح بالفرنسيه يمكن
لم تتوهله وسائل الاعلام بالعربي كثيره
انها الفوز هذا لابد ان تكون كل الكواكب
والمجرات
متناسقه ومنسجمه حتى يتحقق هذا الفوز
فيعني صعوبه هذا الفوز كانت كبيره جدا
استاذ القميحي بهذا الاسم
يا زميل العزيز محمد دائما في ثقافه الغرب
في نوعا ما تقليل من اهميه المنتخبات
العربيه وشانها في المونديال وحتى نحن
كعرب لما بتيجي يعني بالغالب لما بتساله
مين بتشجع بالمونديال نادرا لتسمع انه
المنتخب عربي بالدرجه الاولى دايما منتخب
غربي الى اي حد مباراه امس او نحنا في
المستقبل سنكسر هذه الثقافه هذه الصوره
النبطيه وهذا ما فعلته السعوديه امس
برايكم
ضد المنتخبات العربيه هذه الاحصائيات وهذه
المواقف اتخذت بناء على الارقام منتخبات
العربيه ما كان لها حضور الله فاتت كنا
نسميها احيانا في اقصى الحالات
بهدف او تعاد ف نحن نسميه تعادل او هزيمه
مشرف بالتالي المواقف في الغربيه
بالمنتخبات العربيه بانها كانت تحقق نتائج
المنتخب السعودي على المنتخب الارجنتيني
الذي كان من المتوقع ان يفوز بالبطوله
وبكم النجوم انا اول ما شفت التشكيله قلت
ههه خلاص
يتعاملون مع المباراه بجديه يعني لما يكون
ميسي موجود في راس الحربه مع منتخب
المنتخب السعودي التشريحات ما كانت تعطي
حقه فبالتاكيد كانوا هم يتعاملوا مع
الموضوع بجديه ولكن تفاجئوا باللعب
الرجوله والشجاعه المنتخب السعودي شباب
كان عندهم توجيهات واضحه انه اعطوا افضل
ما عندكم بدون اي ضغوط ممكن العالم ما
يتوقع منكم شيء في احنا نتوقع منكم دائما
الافضل ولكن استمتعه وفعلا هم استمتعوا
امس وان تعون بنتيجه تاريخيه
لانه كان ادائهم رجولي كان عندهم هدف انه
يصنعوا المستحيل
وهذا اللي صنع المنتخب السعودي يوم امس
يعني اليوم حارس المرمى محمد العويس منح
الصقور انتصارا غاليا ضد الارجنتين هل
يمكن اعتباره رجل المباراه بعد ان انقذ
مرناه من عده هجمات
قوي بالنسبه للمنتخب الارجنتيني لكن لا
يعني انا اعتبر ان الفريق ككل يعني هو رجل
المباراه كل اللاعبين ادوا بمئه بالمئه
قدموا قتاليه روح انتصاريه كبيره همم يعني
حرام انه يعني نظلم لاعب على حساب اخر
الحارس او الدفاع او الوسط او الهجوم كلهم
كانوا رجال يستحقون الاشاده والاحترام
لمقدمه للمنتخب السعودي اعتقد ان هي بدايه
المنتخب السعودي اليوم يعني دخل في اجواء
المونديال ودخل من الباب الكبير طبعا
الفوز امام الارجنتين يجعل الطموحات كبيره
سقف انتظرت الجما اكبر واكبر فالمنتخب
السعودي اليوم امام اختبار اخر لان اليوم
لابد من المرور الى الدور الثاني مجرد
الفوز في المباراه المقبله اعتقد انه
المنتخب السعودي سيحصل مبكرا تصدر مجموعه
نعم قلت بان هذا الفوز العكس حتى على اداء
المنتخب التونسي وسيرعكس ان شاء الله
اليوم على اداء المنتخب المغربي وبالتالي
فعلا سقف التوقعات ارتفعت لكن هناك ايضا
جانب مهم جدا للفريق امس 11 لاعب
لعبوا بروح الفريق بغض النظر وين الانتماء
كلها باي فريق اي منتخب لكن
ياسر الشهراني الذي اصيب اصابته
وبخير فعلا كل لاعب ادى بجهد وحماس وكانوا
ينظرون الى ميسي بانه اسطوره هو فعلا
اسطوره ولكن اسطوره لا تهزم البارح
الاسطوره هزمت وفاز المنتخب السعودي
النتيجه 2-1 انا شخصيا راح بروزها في
البيت سواء كان احتفل معنا البرازيل او
احتفل معنا اي شخص في العالم الاحتفال كان
لكل العرب لنا فتره ما شفنا العرب في كل
الدول العربيه في كل المدن العربيه
يحتفلون بفوز منتخب عربي الفوز اللي واحد
كل العرب اوروبا
ضد الارجنتين ههه
يعني بس كمان انا في عندي امر انه من
ناحيه تقنيه انت كخبير رياضي منير لاحظنا
يعني اغلبيه العالم اللي عم تحضر انه كان
المنتخب السعودي مهاجم هذه المره مش مدافع
كانه مش مش بس يترقب الهدف من ميسي فبده
يحمي مرماه وهذا كان الامر لافت يعني شو
تفسيرك هذا الهدف المبكر المنتخب
الارجنتيني يعني هذا الشيء كل الضغوطات
على اللاعبين خلاص
الخوف من استقبل الهاتف حصل المنتخب
الارجنتيني يسجل يسجل يعني في الاول ربع
ساعه اليوم انتهى يعني لابد انك تلعب
تستمتع فوزت او خساره خلاص يعني ما ما
هيفرق لكن رده الفعل كانت يعني رجوليه
وقويه واداء قتاليه فشفنا خاصه في الشوط
الثاني والتوجيهات المدرب كانت مهمه جدا
انه خلاص العب العب انت يعني استمتع على
الاقل هذا كاس عالم يمكن ان تلعب يعني مره
واحده في مسيرته كلاعب م- يعني
فشاهدنا للمنتخب يلعب بدون اي ضغوطات بدون
اي مركب نقص يعني تجاه اللاعبين الارجنتين
اللاعبين الارجنتين في النهايه يعني
مشاهير العالم نتكلم عليها ديماريا نتكلم
عليها لوتروا في خط هجوم نتكلم عليها ميسي
فلا لعيب الهجوم في كل الانديه العالميه
لكن همم
القتالي والرغبه في رد الفعل اسمعت في
النهايه هدف تعادل هدف تعادل كان لو مفعول
السحر يعني خرج كل طاقه اللاعبين المنتخب
السعودي
لياقه كبيره كانت عند المنتخب السعودي في
تجهيز كبير جدا غير الجانب المعنوي وكان
عندهم صراحه مدرب
تكتيك التسلل بهذه الطريقه حرمان
الارجنتين من ثلاثه اهداف طبعا تسلل يعني
صراحه منتخب عالمي يستطيع فقط ان يلعب
الطريقه ويتقنها على مدى شوطين المباراه
وينقل الكره والمباراه من المنتخب السعودي
مباشره الى الملعب المنتخب ارجنتيني
بصراحه هذا ذهب من المدرب هذا قدره همم
استثنائيه ايضا من الفريق اللي يطبق همم
استراتيجيه بهذا النوع خاصه في وجود تقنيه
حديثه بهذا القدره ويحرم من الاندنتين من
ثلاثه اهداف وانعكس ايجابيا على معنويات
المنتخب السعودي
كيف احتفلوا عن طريقه رونالدو هذه المره
[تصفيق]
محمد العويس حارس مرمى المنتخب السعودي
رجل المباراه وحديث الاعلام الرياضي
العالمي لم يبخل بقطره عرق حتى النهايه
واستحق ارشادات مشجعي كره القدم في كل
مكان وبكل لغات العالم ضغط شديد يحمله على
ظهره قبل الممتع الهجوم الكبير بسبب تذبذب
مستواه ترصد من بعض الجماهير لاخطائه في
المباريات الوديه وانتقدات للمدرب الفني
السعودي هذه رينار الذي اصر عليه حارسا
اساسيا الاخضر السعودي في المباراه الاولى
للمونديال يرد العويس بادائه البطوله
يتصدى لخمس كرات بامت ويقفك الجبل طوال
اكثر من 100 دقيقه العمر ويخمد البركان
الارجنتيني بمنتهى الثبات راينا العويس
ايضا يخرج من مرماه ليعوض تقدم الدفاع
ويتدخل على الكره ليافتكها ببراعه قبل
انفراد مهاجم الارجنتين في المرمى ويحبط
اكثر من هجمه واحده ومحققه للتسجيل محمد
العويس رجل المباراه الاولى في مشوار
السعوديه بالمونديال والاعلى تقيما طبقا
لجميع منصات الرياضيه العالميه تجاوز
الاختبار الاصعب بجداره وينتظره تحديا
اخران في المجموعه امام ليفاندوفسكي
والمنتخب البولنديه يوم السبت والمكسيك في
المباراه الاخيره
دكتور نادر الحديث عن تحمل الضغط النفسي
دكتور اهلا بك لفتتني نقطه ذكرها استاذنا
محمد همم انه المنتخب السعودي
كمنتخب قوي لانه لعب بعيدا عن الضغط
النفسي لاعب بحماس وبمتعه حدثنا اكثر عن
الموضوع
يعني يمكن في الوطن العربي ما بنتبه فيه
حساء اسمه علم الطب النفسي الرياضي يمكن
اكتر الانديه الموجودين في اوروبا
اللاسف الانديه الانجليزيه عندها حتى في
فريق عنده اربعه من الاخصائيين النفسيين
اللي بيشتغلوا هذا الشيء دائما احنا بنقول
لعيبه الرياضه نوعين يا لعيب اللي احنا
بنسميه زي الليمون كل ما بتعصر الليمونه
اكثر بيطلع على الجوده تبعته اكثر وفي
اللي احنا بنسميه زي الاسفنج اللي بيمتص
كل شيء الجيد والغير جيد اللاعب بيبقى
دائما لما بيكون في همم في المباراه مش
عنده ضغط فقط انه يفوز عنده ضغط ملايين
الناس اللي بتتابع هذا التيشرت بغض النظر
المنتخب او نادي عنده الناس اللي بيكون في
ضغط غير طبيعي الصوت الناس اللي في الملعب
صوت الجماهير الاعتراضات هذه كلها هذه
بتكون صعب انك انت تقدر تستوعي بيها الا
اذا كان في متابع نفسنا تفضل
هل نفسيا مستعدا لانه في حتى هو تفاهات قد
تكون كثيره ضده وهو يلعب
انا سمعته من بعض الاخصاصين اللي بيشتغلوا
مع اللعيبه الكوره بالذات انك انت لما
تنزل الملعب اعتبر نفسك قاعد في البحر
قاعد في مكان مش موجود في الجمهور كله
لانه الجمهور هيسقف لك لما هتدخل الهدف
وهيزعل منك وممكن يتسبك او يعترض عليك لما
انت ما تدخل الهدف والعكس صحيح حتى مع
الحارس المرمى لانه حارس المرمى كان
بيعتبروه 50% من قوه الفريق فدائما
بينصحوا اللعيبه انك انت ما تهتم بغض
النظر انت احرز هدف او ما احرس هدف ما
تهتم هذه النقطه المهمه جدا الفرق اللي
بتنجح اكثر اللي دائما ما بيكون عليها
ضغوط نفسيه لما بتنزل المباراه يمكن يكون
نجاح المنتخب السعودي وما عليه ضغط كبير
جدا انه انه لازم انا اكسب في المباراه
لانه هذا الارجنتين وعادي كذا كذا بعض
احيانا عدم وجود الضغط النفسي زي مثلا
موضوع ميسي عدم وجود الضغط النفسي على
ميسي غير على كريستيانو رونالدو مثلا
كريستيانو لما نيجي يشوف الضغط النفسي
الرياضي عليه بالعكس بيفقد اعصابه اسرع
بدليل الاشياء اللي بيسرحها في الصحافه
والاشياء دي كلها لكن ميسي يمكن احنا
بنجده انه اكثر بروده حتى البليله مش لغه
الجسد تبعته لما بيكون بيلعب بينزل يعمل
سكان للملعب كامله الناس حتى في مرات تطلع
ههه هذه هي هذه النقطه المهمه جدا تظهر
الشخصيه لما يكون عندي ضغط اكبر وهذا
ركزنا كثير على المنتخب السعودي ولكن ايضا
على نفسيه المنتخب الارجنتيني وكيف اثرت
على هزيمته للمباراه المنتخب الارجنتيني
اكيد دخل بثقه
بتصريحات الجماهير الجماهير كان يعتبرون
المباراه فقط
مشاكل السلبي على المنتخب وبالتالي الصدمه
التي لم يستيقظ منها المنتخب الارجنتيني
بعد دخول هدف التعادل صحيح وهدف الفوز شوف
انت قول شيء جميل جدا الصدمه هي عارفه علم
النفس دائما في دائما من شيء مفهوم جدا
انا في صدمه باخذها مبدئيا حتى في
البلنتيات انه لما يلعبوا فيه عندي اول
حاجه انا اخذ الصدمه امتص هذه الصدمه
وارجع مره ثانيه دائما بتحصل الخلل ويمكن
هنا انتم يعني كاشخاص لكم علاقه بارده
اكثر الصمام بتحصل دائما انت في خلال اكثر
من خمس دقائق اقل من خمس دقائق لما اي
فريق بياخذ هدف وبيقدر الفريق الثاني يكمل
الضغط عليه هذه اللي احنا في خلال الخمس
دقائق هذه انه يمتص الصدمه الاولانيه
فبنهاره فرق كثيره جدا انهارت في خلال اقل
من خمس دقائق بهدفين او ثلاثه
هيك بدي اعطي تعليق انه دروس في الحياه
مستفاده من مباراه امس انه بس تكبر الخسه
براسك بتفشل
ومش مهم دائما النجاح المهم الاستمراريه
وان تقارن نفسك
عربي لا يعرف المستحيل المستحيل تحقق امس
وبالتالي اي شخص او اي فرد يتوقع بان
امكانياته ممكن يتساعده لا مستحيل امامك
حقق احلامك حقك طموحاتك وعلى فكره ليس هذا
المستوى العربي لكن على المستوى العالمي
تخيل اوكي ممكن هذا الفوز ينعكس على نفسه
دائما اعمل بجهد
باخلاص وبابا رجولي من اجل تحقيقه اهدافك
والله لا تتنازل عن عنان السماء اذا كانت
همتك مثلا مثل المنتخب السعودي مثل الجبل
المغرب
شكرا جزيلا لكم